[Música]
já pararam para pensar que a grande
oportunidade da vida de vocês
poderia estar exatamente no momento mais
difícil dela eu vou contar um pouquinho
da minha história para vocês e vou
mostrar como o nosso pensamento ea forma
de encarar a vida tem o poder de mudar
tudo à nossa volta
há quase três anos no dia 27 de setembro
de 2012
eu estava indo fazer uma viagem de carro
comemorado
nossa primeira viagem juntas de
revellion ea gente decidiu sair bem
cedinho por volta das cinco e meia da
manhã para não pegar trânsito e assim
foi feito
eu desci com duas bolsas e eu resolvi
colocar uma no porta malas porque o
carro já estava muito cheio e aí no
mesmo momento em que tentava colocar só
não pode uma moça estava voltando da
balada e ela tinha bebido algumas alguns
drinques e aí ela perdeu o controle do
carro dela e acabam pensando contra o
carro do meu namorado
nesse momento eu caí esperei por ágil
pro hospital e aí eu tive que passava
por uma cirurgia de 14 horas de duração
antes de eu entrar na cirurgia eu
cheguei pra médica
eu não vou então na época não despedir
de ninguém ainda
e ela me falou não fica tranquila era só
conseguia pensar eu estava tão assustada
mas eu fui tranquila no e e às 14 horas
de duração da cirurgia bem pesadas assis
tentaram salvar minha perna por tudo e
eles não conseguiram eles inclusive
tirar a minha safena tem uma cicatriz
grandona nessa perna mas não foi
possível
então eles tiveram que amputar ea partir
de agora o que eu vou contar pra vocês é
como minha vida mudou totalmente a
partir daquele dia e como eu me tornei
alguém alguém que é uma desafio alguém a
aproveitar a vida ao máximo e mais
importante alguém que encontrou
o propósito de vida naquele digo meus
pais chegaram para me dar a notícia da
amputação 6 horas da manhã ea minha
reação assim de cara foi falar tá bom
graças a deus que eu viva né era só o
que eu conseguia pensar era agradecer e
agradecer
eu senti um alívio tão grande e diz não
ter perdido a minha vida naquele dia que
eu não me viu no direito de reclamar por
ter perdido uma perna
eu tinha várias incertezas assim eu não
sabia como ia ser
eu não conhecia nenhum deputado não
sabia como era uma prótese era cinza
bege mg brilhante né
mas eu sabia que eu não sabia que eu ia
ficar bem como que esse tudo mas eu
resolvi não sofrer por antecipação eu
falei assim vou encarar cada dia uma vez
vamos ver como é que eu tô agora eu só
consigo agradecer
não vamos pensar no amanhã e foi assim
que tudo aconteceu
é mesmo no meio de tantas incertezas
eu ainda tinha várias certeza que cada
dia mais à medida que eu ia ficar no
hospital eu pensava e falava gente isso
não é nada perto da minha vida que é
perder uma perna sendo que eu tô aqui
que eu tenho todo mundo que eu amo eu
podia ter ido embora sem se despedir de
ninguém e isso me deu muita força na
minha recuperação
a minha recuperação não foi fácil eu
achei que eu ia chegar lá e colocar
prótese sai andando e eu tomei um susto
porque fora as dores que já sentia dor
fantasma era muito difícil equilibrar
com a prótese é muito difícil andar com
a prótese doía muito
mas eu queria muito andar então eu
chegava em casa doida pra tirar prótese
e eu não tirava ficava com ela o dia
inteiro e assim rapidinho eu voltei a
andar
eu fui aos poucos voltando a fazer tudo
o que eu já fazia
foi muito legal porque os meus 20 anos
eu pude reaprender a fazer coisas que eu
jamais tinha pensado sobre elas
como por exemplo andar eu nunca tinha
parado para pensar porque o nosso braço
acompanha nossa perna o que quando a
gente faz
uma rampa o nosso tronco têm que
acompanhar nosso corpo e foi muito
especial pra mim isso foi muito valioso
eu falava eu agradeço muito por tá vendo
como essas coisas são incríveis e
portando todo valor a coisas que até os
20 anos eu achava tão pequenas né
e eu voltei a fazer tudo o que eu já
fazia e comecei a fazer coisas que eu
nunca tinha feito antes como dançar
surfar andar de skate
cada dia eu inventando uma coisa nova
eu me comprometi comigo mesma eu não vou
deixar a bola cair
eu vou ficar firme eu quero surpreender
a mim mesma ea todo mundo que está à
minha volta e eu acho que isso foi
possível mas tudo isso foi possível
graças a quatro lições que eu levei
comigo todos os dias e que tiveram assim
um papel fundamental nisso tudo é a
minha primeira edição foi não
supervalorize o que não é essencial pra
você e isso cabe várias interpretações
nessi mas duas eu acho bem importantes
o primeiro tema que eu quero falar sobre
problemas a gente todo mundo tem
problema todo mundo está passando por um
problema agora ou tem problemas enormes
dentro de casa
só que a gente não precisa da o peso
muito grande para eles a gente pode
simplesmente escolher como é que a gente
quer encarar esses problemas eles não
precisam ter um peso enorme você não
precisa perder o seu dia inteiro de fado
bravo por causa desse problema
deixa ele tem um peso menor ea segunda
coisa sobre super valorizar a nossa
beleza assim até meus 20 anos
eu sempre foi focada se em corpo a gente
sempre quer um corpo melhor a gente está
ali malhando exercitando airton
insatisfeita com uma gordurinha e quando
uma coisa dessas acontece quando a gente
sofre um acidente que a gente vê que a
gente podia ter perdido a nossa vida a
gente fala meu deus que bobagem pra que
eu ficava me importando com isso não é
nada
cada um tem suas imperfeições é assim
que a vida é é muito mais legal cada um
tem o narizinho uma gordurinha o tipo de
corpo
imagina se todos
fosse igual a esse tão sem graça né
eu tenho muito orgulho da minha perna da
minha cicatrizes de todas elas no roxo
que eu tenho no joelho porque está
contando a minha história aqui que está
a minha história pelo que eu passei os
meus tom dos meus acertos e eu acho que
a gente devia pensar mais nisso do que
querer sempre melhorar e melhorar e
melhorar a minha segunda lição é que eu
tirei a minha vida é que se você tem uma
idéia seja ela qual for um sonho
vá atrás dela porque pode ser sua última
chance
é quando sofri meu acidente
eu tenho dois exemplos que são pequenos
mas representam muito isso é quando
sofri meu acidente
eu tinha acabado de trancar uma
faculdade de administração que eu tinha
entrado e fiz um ano e meio mas meu
sonho sempre tinha sido fazer jornalismo
e mas eu não quis fazer jornalismo
porque era muito difícil da seta é uma
profissão complicada e eu fui tentando
não dar certo em administração estava
fazendo cursinho e aí dois dias depois
do meu acidente eu falei meu deus eu
tenho que fazer jornalismo rápido o meu
sonho é o que eu amo eu ia ter morrido
com 20 anos sem fazer o que eu amo e
gastar dias da minha vida sem fazer o
que eu amo preocupada com o retorno que
cm da qual o sentido disso eu quero ser
feliz e era algo que eu tinha muitos é o
segundo exemplo é uma coisa muito
curiosa assim mas a primeira coisa que
eu queria fazer depois do acidente era
fazer uma tatuagem
ninguém estava entendendo como assim tem
tanta coisa para fazer porque ela quer
fazer uma tatuagem mas logo antes do meu
acidente eu queria fazer uma tatuagem
e eu falei não vou fazer muito nova vou
arrepender com certeza mais pra frente e
aí eu falei meu deus olha tanto de coisa
que eu ia deixar de fazer como base em
números de arrepender
então eu fui com as duas muletas ainda
sem prótese no estúdio
tatuagem esses três de uma vez
vejo com 10 né não sei quando vou parar
mas esse pequeno gesto assim
isso pra mim representou muito porque
representa uma liberdade estava
aprisionada nas coisas que eu tinha medo
de fazer por medo de arrepender quando
eu vi que a vida é tão frágil falei eu
não posso fazer isso vamos aproveitar a
minha terceira lição e que é super
importante para mim é sobre medo o medo
está sempre aqui
cada um tem seus medos medo é uma coisa
totalmente individual
tem gente que tem medo de perder alguém
tem gente que tem medo de algum animal e
eu depois do acidente eu desenvolvi um
medo muito grande um de carro eu fiquei
com medo sem noção espacial
mas o maior foi de avião e era um pânico
assim é difícil explicar para quem
talvez nunca sofreu disso vai ter mão
suava eu passava mal eu chorava
era muito difícil pra mim e e aí meu
primeiro trabalho fora de belo horizonte
eles me convidaram um desfile em são
paulo e ao mesmo tempo que eu fiquei
muito feliz meu deus meu desfile é como
é que vai ser isso tudo eu falei eu acho
que eu não vou eu vou inventar uma
desculpa vou falar que o doente porque
estou com muito medo estou pressentindo
algo ruim eu acho que não vai dar certo
e eu fiquei uma semana pensando no que
fazer
e aí eu decidi e foi muito importante
para mim porque eu tenho ido foi o ponto
até foi o que me libertou foi o que
tornou possível a minha vida se assim
hoje eu viajo semanalmente viaja às
vezes várias vezes por semana faço vôos
internacionais internacionais sozinha e
isso talvez não teria sido possível nada
disso teria acontecido se eu tivesse
deixado medo me vencer aquele dia eu
falo que talvez o mesmo fique comigo o
resto da minha vida
mas o que eu sempre vou poder escolher é
como eu enfrento meu medo como eu encaro
o meu medo
tem uma frase que eu levo sempre comigo
que é
corajoso não é aquele que não tem medo é
aquele que tem medo e que mesmo assim
vai lá e faz isso em todos os aspectos
da nossa vida
medo de arriscar medo da mudança medo de
mudar de trabalho de casa
isso me leva a minha última lição e pra
mim é mais importante talvez uma tudo
que é sobre mudança mudanças acontecem a
todo momento a hora está passando tem
alguém mexendo a mão à cabeça e tem
mudança de todos os jeitos mudanças
grandes e pequenas boas ruins há algumas
que a gente escolhe outras que não o que
a gente sempre vai poder escolher é como
a gente age depois dessas mudanças
eu perdi a minha perna nova mudança que
eu escolhi foi o que aconteceu comigo
mas aquele momento estava lidando com o
fato nada do que eu fizesse a trazer a
pena de volta nada eu tinha perdido eu
podíamos ficar triste perguntar por que
comigo bem naquela hora eu não viajar
eu podia falar bora ver o que estão
esperando ver como é essa vida esse
mundo que eu não sei como vai ser isso é
muito legal isso mudou tudo
eu tenho certeza que se não tivesse
enfrentado a minha mudança com otimismo
eu não estaria aqui hoje talvez minha
vida totalmente diferente do que ela
está hoje
depois dessas quatro edições começou a
pesar muito pra mim assim eu quero ficar
perto da minha família dos meus amigos
em casa
eu valorizo tanto eles nós eu vejo como
nossa vida valiosa quero aproveitar cada
segundinho mas mesmo tempo estou
viajando mais do que o normal tudo ficar
conhecidos do que com as pessoas que eu
amo e por que está fazendo isso tudo pra
que dê o que me motivou emotivo até hoje
é saber que eu posso ajudar pessoas
eu posso ajudar tanto pessoas que estão
na mesma situação que eu ou pessoas que
não estão pessoas que estão precisando
talvez de um estímulo para viver em
liberdade para aceitarem é isso que me
motiva todos os dias eu tenho tantos
planos eu tenho tantas coisas que eu
quero fazer ainda porque quando eu sofri
meu acidente
eu falei eu não sei por que isso
aconteceu quando a pessoa me falava uma
coisa eu não sei mas eu quero levar isso
como uma missão
eu quero pegar esse fato ruim que várias
pessoas considerava esse acidente é uma
coisa ruim tinha acontecido comigo e
quero tornar a missão da minha vida eu
quero fazer disso um verdadeiro
propósito ia pra esse protótipo e vocês
o que vocês estão fazendo dos momentos
difíceis da vida de vocês
obrigada
[Aplausos]